en el mes más letal desde el inicio de
la pandemia en colombia la tercera ola
del cobi 19 no da signos de retroceder
con cifras que no disminuyen desde
mediados de abril y se espera que sigan
empeorando hasta finales de mes el
gobierno flexibilizó las restricciones a
principios de junio para reactivar la
economía una decisión que generó
opiniones encontradas en este momento ya
prácticamente a lo mismo tener las
personas guardadas que tenerlas en la
calle porque ya los que están infectados
están infectados y los que están
infectados están guardando sus casas y
están infectando a su réplica en réplica
mente a su núcleo familiar a pesar de
que el programa de vacunación arrancó
con retrasos el gobierno está intentando
acelerarlo para combatir el virus para
lo que llegaron más de un millón de
dosis de facer en la última semana algo
que no ha evitado que el sistema
sanitario esté al borde del colapso con
tasas de ocupación en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos superiores al 96 por
ciento en las principales ciudades del
país como bogotá la capital campo
o ha frenado el número de muertes
diarias que sigue batiendo récords y que
ha aumentado la carga de trabajo en las
funerarias y crematorios frente a los
servicios jóvenes el incremento y mucho
mayor ya que en ese periodo de tiempo de
enero a mayo del año 2020 tuvimos 4
servicios mientras que para este año
tuvimos 246 servicios los expertos
advierten de que la vacunación no es
suficiente y destacan la importancia de
seguir con las medidas de autocuidado
para conseguir frenar la curva de
contagios y decesos